hello and good morning welcome to Sky
News breakfast now against a background
of pay settlements and new Talks by some
striking unions Railway workers will
walk outs today for the second time this
week bringing many services across the
country to a standstill members of the
rmt had 14 of the country's train
operating companies are taking strike
action with no sign of their
long-running dispute over paying
conditions being resolved and there's a
warning this morning that Easter holiday
getaways could be under threat as there
are strikes due by airport and passport
stuff
well there was some optimism in
Government after it announced that
teachers would be in talks with the
governments this weekend and have called
off their next round of strikes NHS
workers have also suspended further
strikes and are recommending that their
members accept a new payoffer
while Junior doctors in England have
agreed to formal talks with the
government after a three-day strike this
week however other strikes show no sign
of coming to an end as Railway workers
University lecturers and people who work
of people who are members of the public
sector unions continue their strike
actions some of these strikes are
escalating with staff at passport
officers announcing five weeks of strike
action from the 3rd of April and
security guards at Heathrow Airport will
strike over Easter the public and
Commercial Services union says there's
little reason to be hopeful of a
breakthrough
well I'm pleased to say that Alice
Porter is with us now live from Houston
Station this morning Alice good to have
you with us so uh another day of misery
on the railway networks for people
trying to use this use the system
that's right we've only got about half
of services that are operating in the
country today here at Houston I've just
had a look we've got about one train an
hour going to Birmingham but I think
it's important stress London of course
is immensely well connected and there'll
be parts of the country where there'll
be simply no services at all on what
would be normally a busy Saturday for
lots of people wanting to go about their
business now this is very much because
of a long-running dispute with the rmt
Union this has actually been going on
since June but it seems that there's no
way at the moment this is going to be
resolved anytime soon Network Railway
put forward a pay offer for this year or
five percent and four percent for next
financial year but that was uh rejected
by the rmt union last month and that's
why this industrial action just keeps on
happening we've got this is the second
day today we've got further strike
action at the end of month and April and
we've got really a sort of stalemate
really between the governments and the
rmt unit the rmt union say they want an
unconditional offer and the government's
saying that is a the final offer on the
table so there's a sort of stalemate
there but there has been some excellent
progress this week if we look to the NHS
for example we had a real breakthrough
in talks with Stephen Barkley and uh the
unions representing nurses and ambulance
workers and that offer is going to be
put to its members with all but one who
are going to be encouraging their
members to accept it but crucially a lot
of those unions have been asking for an
above inflation pay right so well above
10 and the the offer from Stephen
Barkley is five percent so is that going
to be enough for people to to vote on it
we don't quite net yo and I think
there's been some momentum there I think
because there's been progress in the
talks there we've got potentially
Stephen Barkley and the junior doctors
who may well be meeting as early as next
week that's not being timetabled yet but
they will be having to sit down but
crucially they've got a lot of
negotiations to go through remember the
junior doctors are striking for a 35 pay
rise and Stephen Barkley says that
simply on affordable bought so they're
going to have to find a way of meeting
in the middle but I think the government
will at least be pleased that these
talks means industrial action is caused
off we've seen such huge disruption to
our schools over the last couple of
weeks with teachers going on strike
that's been paused for the moment to
allow talks to to carry on uh same with
Junior doctors same with nurses so the
government will be pleased whilst
they're desperately trying to bring down
waiting lists we've heard this week 175
000 procedures and operations had to be
postponed so the government's under
pressure when it comes to the NHS so
we'll be delighted at the very least
these talks are happening so there's
progress made there but ultimately until
strikes are called off it's still a very
uncertain time and it feels like as soon
as one strike is called off yet another
one appears we heard of the last couple
of days passport office workers with the
PCS Union they're going to be doing five
weeks of strikes and then we've got
issues with the baggage handlers in
Heathrow so it still feels like we've
got a long way to go and still seems
like we've got a many weeks and
potentially months ahead where we could
have disruption like we're seeing today
across our rail Networks we'll be
speaking to the boss of the rmt make
Lynch later on this morning now that's
for now at Houston thank you
foreign
state says that the international
criminal court is right to have issued
an arrest warrant for the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and for
Russia's commissioner on children's
rights the court has accused them of war
crimes including the illegal deportation
of children to Russia the Kremlin says
the indictment is outrageous and
unacceptable
the move highlights the importance of
the visits to Russia next week by the
Chinese president Xi Jinping our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wyghorn has this
it is an extraordinary development in
this war Vladimir Putin the leader of a
U.N security Council permanent member
Nation facing an International arrest
warrant and for the most serious of war
crimes
Sky News was the first to reveal video
evidence of Russian soldiers searching a
place of sanctuary in Ukraine looking
for children this was one orphanage in
her son where orphans were abducted at
gunpoint by the Russian military
these children among thousands across
Ukraine said to have been taken by the
Russians during this war
allegations now the focus of
international criminal court arrest
warrants that go to the very top of the
Russian government their international
criminal court is issued two warrants of
arrest in the Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
commissioner of the Russian president
from children's right for the alleged
World crimes of deportation of children
from Ukrainian occupied territories
entered the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories this was Vladimir Putin
meeting his children's rights
commissioner last month the arrest
warrants against both are being welcomed
by Ukraine's president zielinski
separating children from their families
depriving them of any opportunity to
contact their relatives Hiding Children
on the territory of Russia thrown them
in remote regions all this is an obvious
State policy of Russia State decisions
and state evil which begins precisely
with the top official of this state
the warrants mean Vladimir Putin must
think very carefully about where he
travels and make the Russian leader even
more of an international Pariah the
Kremlin and its mouthpieces have reacted
with Fury my attractions at first of all
is Big stupidity and irresponsibility of
the international
criminal court it's uh the police of
Russian government to save children not
to steal children but to save children
from their Frontline Zone
so what are the chances of Vladimir
Putin going from wartime leader to the
accused in an international court of law
we have to be very realistic that we're
not going to see uh Putin in The Hague
anytime soon and of course there'll be a
lot of cynicism as to whether we will
ever see him there of course we won't be
looking at a trial In Absentia at the
ICC the move puts Putin in the dubious
company a former Libyan leader Muammar
Gaddafi and Sudanese president Omar
al-Bashir both indicted by the ICC but
never tried Vladimir Putin may be able
to elude prosecution for now but that
doesn't mean this move doesn't have real
significance it's important because this
man is now as many would say he should
have been said to be from a couple of
weeks after the war started labeled as a
criminal
and that's going to be make it much much
more difficult for the Coalition of
countries supporting Ukraine to separate
out and to say oh we shouldn't be
carrying on with this war
next week China's president Xi Jinping
flies to Moscow for talks with Vladimir
Putin his host will be an alleged war
criminal how might that influence his
next move the answer to that could be
crucial in the next stage of this war
Dominic wagorn Sky News
now among those who have come out in
support of that ICC warm is Joe Biden he
says it's clear that President Putin has
violated international law
well I think it Justified this but the
question is not recognized
internationally by us either but I think
it makes the very strong point he's
clearly committed War crime
now according to the icc's chief
prosecutor hundreds of Ukrainian
children have been taken from orphanages
and transported to Russia but in Ukraine
it's reported that some 16 000 children
have been taken Chief correspondent
Stuart Ramsey and his team have spoken
to families living in Kiev and in the
nepro about their challenges in getting
their children home this is his report
foreign
ly tracked down and was reunited with
her daughter Nastia after months of
separation
she had traveled thousands of miles
through Russia to Crimea to rescue her
daughter
says she was effectively tricked into
letting her go on a trip organized by
the authorities
um
[Music]
like thousands of children Nastia joined
what was described as a summer camp but
she says it wasn't that at all
this
is
when Russia paraded a group of Ukrainian
children on a Moscow stage with a
soldier claiming that they were saved
from Ukraine it caused outrage here
Ukraine has been telling the world that
its children were effectively being
kidnapped by Russia to turn them against
their mother country the ICC appears to
agree
president zielinski has been calling for
Action from the ICC since the start of
the year and doubtless he'll be pleased
as will his government about these
latest developments but it's probably
fair to say it'll not make much
difference in the short term that means
that many Ukrainian children will remain
in Russian territory
save Ukraine is an NGO that's dedicated
itself to helping families get their
children back
they say Russia had a detailed strategy
and plan to take the children
they thought this through for I don't
know maybe for not even
um
for us who who we must look at this from
the perspective of History
so it's nothing new
and this was this whole thing was
prepared and what do they do with
children it's like a part of bigger
policy that's all against Ukraine and
that's been thought about as a proper
plan yeah yeah we stand that it was not
only about
full-scale invasion in 2022 yeah it was
prepared long before this
the exact number of children who have
left Ukraine and may never be seen here
again isn't known
but the ICC moves May one day at least
bring someone responsible to Justice
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine
now the Home Secretary swella Bravo is
in Rwanda to highlight the government's
plan to send migrants to the country
let's bring in our political
correspondent Rob palp who was in
Westminster for us this morning Rob so
uh swella has landed in Rwanda what's
she going to be doing while she's there
so she's going to be meeting the
president the foreign minister she's
going to be visiting some of the sites
the accommodation that's linked to the
controversial
um deportation scheme that was signed
about a year ago by her predecessor
pretty Patel the Home Secretary landed
um in Kigali the Rwandan capital in the
last um couple of hours you can see her
playing uh there I think the point of
this trip is to initially try and remind
voters in the UK that the government is
still serious about this plan to deport
people who arrive in the UK by crossing
the channel on small boats to Rwanda and
force them to claim Asylum there
um the discussions the Home Secretary
says will focus on how they plan to get
the scheme to work operationally so I
think they want to give out the
impression that they haven't abandoned
the plan clearly it's tied up in legal
challenges at the moment and no one so
far has actually been deported to Rwanda
under it I think this is also
potentially about reassuring the Rwandan
government that the UK still wants to
pursue you this the Home Secretary has
been pushing back in remarks overnight
on the suggestion that only 200 people
could be accommodated in Rwanda through
this scheme she says actually that's the
capacity of one of the initial reception
hostels and that actually thousands of
people could potentially be taken to
Rwanda under this of course the scheme
in general remains controversial the
Home Secretary has said again overnight
that in her view Rwanda is one of the
safest countries in the world clearly
documents that were Unearthed during the
legal challenge show that even within
government there has been a degree of
caution about the human rights record of
Rwanda and concern about whether the UK
should be involved in this respect with
this country I think in the near term
the thing that is going to have probably
the greater impact on cutting numbers of
people crossing the channel in small
boats is actually going to be all of the
money being given to the French to beef
up security there rather than
controversial schemes like this but I
think the fact that it is seen as
inflammatory by many as part of the
point for the government because this is
about politics as well as practicalities
and sending a message out to voters that
it's taking a robust and strong stance
on this I guess the worry that people
have that deal with refugees and people
that are fleeing War zones is that in a
bid to essentially send this message out
to voters some of the most vulnerable
people in the world fleeing from
perilous situations may be caught up and
damaged by it
okay Rob uh in Westminster for now thank
you
all right let's take a look at some
other stories that are making news this
morning and a convicted murderer who
tackled a terrorists during the 2019
fishmongers Hall attackers among those
to be awarded for his bravery Stephen
Gannon confronted as Moon Khan as he
carried out his attack during a prison
education conference three other men who
helped bring Khan down are also to be
honored
Wyoming has become the first state in
the United States to ban abortion pills
legal fights over abortion rights
continue Across America after the rights
to access abortion was overturned by the
Supreme Court last year
and the motoring company the RAC says
that diesel drivers are not currently
benefiting from the freeze in a fuel
Duty despite wholesale diesel costs
falling to a 15-month low they say that
major fuel retailers have refused to cut
prices at the pump in any meaningful way
now there were clashes in Paris between
police and protesters overnight with 61
people being arrested it follows the
decision by the French governments to
push through a rise in the state pension
age from 62 to 64. president macron now
faces two motions of no confidence
tabled by the opposition after he forced
that legislation through without giving
Parliament a vote
well our International correspondent
Alex Rossi is in the French Capital
Paris for us and sent us this report
rioting as demonstrators lit fires and
confronted the police in the place de la
Concourse
Fury here and across France at president
macron's plan to raise the retirement
age from 62 to 64. hello Henry because
even if we're protest they will just do
a 49.3 and there is no difference
between a special constitutional power
yes yes and it's only here in France so
it's very hungry you feel it's
anti-democratic yes
[Music]
change it's very unfair for everyone a
lot of people manifested in foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the nation is now braced for much more
of this protesters once again lobbing
missiles at the police
the backdrop to this standoff the lower
house of parliament which the government
bypassed instead using special
Constitutional Powers to force through
the legislation it is difficult to
overstate just how angry people are at
president macron's pension reforms the
big question now is whether or not the
strikes the demonstrations and even the
riots become more frequent in the days
weeks and months to come and bring
paralysis to this country France has
been dealing with rolling strikes and
direct actions for a couple of months
since the plan was announced and perhaps
nothing symbolizes this crisis more than
the bags of uncollected rubbish clogging
up the capital streets
in this country a dignified and
comfortable retirement is seen as an
inalienable right after years of hard
work and it cuts to the core of what it
means to be French
but the government claims with an aging
population reform is unavoidable if the
system is not to buckle and break
more nightly protests are now planned
and the next few days will be a big test
for the government and a nation which is
seething at the prospect of having to
work longer
Alex Rossi Sky News Paris
[Applause]
let's get some analysis on what's
happening in France right now by
speaking to the political commentator
anyus Poirier who's joining us from
Paris good morning to you Agnes and
thanks very much for being with us just
first of all just give us a sense of
what it's like in Paris right now and
across the country how are people
feeling
well I mean it's not as if we're not
used to riots and to uh protest
um so what what we're saying what we saw
yesterday for the first second night in
Paris at the place called The Very uh
beautiful Square where the guillotine
used to stand during the French
Revolution and which is crucially
opposite the National Assembly uh it's
just a few thousand uh young people and
facing the police I mean those scenes
are quite familiar to us now
um of course the the president and the
government will be watching very closely
because uh I don't know if you remember
in 2018 the yellow vest movement uh
really uh um widened the government in
its violence and it's in in its radical
ways and the president asked his uh
interior Minister yesterday to let him
know of everything that is happening in
the country because there is there's a
possibility that trade unions
who have called for another day of
action next Thursday and of general
strike uh might also
be if you like outflanked by a very
violent protest On The Fringe and this
is certainly something that the the
president the government will want to
avoid but this is this is uh you know
difficult the situation is quite
volatile because of the use of article
49.3 which is constitutional which is
perfectly legal which has been used many
times before but on such a heated topic
such an emotional if you'd like topic
such as the pension reform uh it is a
gamble it is a political Gamble and
Widow prison by Conway doesn't shy away
from taking risks but that may be one
political risk to many yeah it means
quite in one of the papers this morning
and saying you have to take your risk I
mean you've laid out for us and there's
the there is a sort of a a timeline of
where we may see these demonstrations
going but talk to us about the political
timeline as well there's motions uh of
censure that motions of no confidence
have been tabled when are we going to
get a vote on that and what are the
chances that macron could lose that vote
because it's the left and the right of
table those motions
well there have been uh votes of no
confidence uh before against President
macron because it doesn't hold a
majority at the assembly they were all
rejected it is likely that there's these
ones on Monday uh will be rejected
um look if it passed it's quite simple
uh the pension reform law won't pass and
uh will be uh will be going to the bin
of history and the French government
will fall that is to say the president
will have to appoint a new uh prime
minister and a new government
um and he could although he's not
obliged to do so he could also choose to
dissolve the National Assembly and
therefore to summon a new legislative
elections
um again that would be a high political
gamble but we're not there yet
um it's uh it's on Monday
um but even you know if the no
confidence vote is rejected which is
likely
um then the pension reform will be made
into law but I doubt the protest will
die down
um as a consequence uh you know the the
volatility and the trade unions which on
this subject are really United will want
to make their voice heard so
um you know uh it's the backlash in the
streets you know in the end in France uh
the the power is with the people and uh
President Michael knows this yeah he
doesn't do our Agnes really appreciate
your analysis as always thank you for
your time this morning and have a good
weekend thank you now with some unions
ask their members to accept a new
payoffer and there are new talks
involving others Railway workers from
the rmt are walking out today for the
second time this week let's speak to the
Union's general secretary Mick Lynch who
joins us now live from Houston Lynch
good morning to you thank you for being
with us this morning so I mean what
happened to that optimism that was
around the turn of the year that this
deal could be settled
well I'm still optimistic but we haven't
got an offer that um we can consider the
companies came up with a package
recently that we put to our members in a
mass consultation all around the country
and they found that the conditions
attach that very modest offer poor offer
really are not acceptable so there's a
debate going on between us and the
companies about what what they should do
next they've got to get a mandate from
the government we're expecting to meet
with them early next week possibly
Tuesday
to discuss the next steps that they've
really got to put some new money on the
table and they've got to take away these
these conditions that our members find
unacceptable and hopefully if we can do
that through constructive conversation
we can put a package to our people for
them to considering a vote but at the
moment it's just not there so it's the
money and it's the conditions just make
you know this has been running on for as
you as you are known as passengers know
for for um a good few months now what
are those conditions that your members
cannot accept
well the companies have stated to me
across the table they're going to close
every ticket office in Britain they're
going to introduce new contracts of
employment that will lower the wages not
increase them the new new starters in
our industry
they want to lower the wages of guards
they want to bring driver only operation
across the network as a principal so
that in the future
there will be no second person on train
even in the city trains that are
operating out of Houston here
they they want to dilute the sick pay
they want to dilute our holiday pay they
want to
make Sunday working mandatory in areas
where it's never been mandatory so
people get no choices I think there are
18 items of conditionality on this offer
and the offer itself is below half the
rate of inflation over the two years
that this dispute has been in 22 and 23
and of course we haven't had a pay rise
in this industry for three years so if
you stack all that up it's a very poor
offer compared to the problems that our
members are facing the cost of living
crisis and all the rest of it but what
is really at the Forefront of our
members thinking is the conditions of
employment and the benefits that we get
from our employment are being diluted as
they have been for so many workers in
Britain many of whom are on a casual
basis uh on zero hours and all the rest
of it where other people have gone and
we're not going to tolerate that we need
good benefits we need proper agreements
and we don't want these conditions
imposed upon us we want an agreement on
the future of the Railway
yeah we don't have loads of time do you
want to get a few more questions to you
I mean you get any sense that with the
fact that nurses unions and unions
representing paramedics are asking their
members to accept their payoffer and
teachers are in talks here in the junior
doctors want to have talks as well any
sense of that's going to affect your
negotiating positions they're pressure
telling now for you guys to try and say
settle an agreement
well the pressure on us is from our
members our members need a deal that
they can accept what the difference
between our negotiations and everybody
else's it seems so if you take the fire
service teachers nurses doctors there
are no conditions this is new money
that's been introduced the the back pay
elements that they've put in last week
and the future payments there are no
conditions they're not saying to nurses
you've got to work different shifts
they're not saying to doctors you've got
to take less sick pay or lower pensions
in fact they're boosting doctors
pensions it seems from the headlines
I've seen they're saying to us in the
railway Railway pension scheme that
they're going to increase the
contributions and lower the benefits so
we call it strings attached it's the
strings that are attached to this deal
that really concern our people we're
realistic about what we can achieve on
money but nobody else seems to have
these conditions imposed upon them and
equally nobody else is working for
companies in the public sector that are
making vast profits since the pandemic
these companies have made 400 million
pounds of profit they're going to make a
over 118 million pounds this year and
they're paying their directors vast
amounts of money millions of pounds
being paid in individual salaries and
one of the directors had their salary
increased by 275 last year so that's not
acceptable we've got to get a bit of
fairness in this system and and make you
mentioned you've got pressure for new
members what about pressure from the the
public I mean you said this week that
um when strike action's not on many of
these um train operating companies can't
run the railways properly anywhere then
you add further pressure to that when
there is Strike action what's the public
meant to do
well we're sorry for the inconvenience
of the public but what the public are
caught in a system that is completely
incompetent the man the companies that
are extracting these profits from the
passengers and from the taxpayer
care about whether there is a good level
of service because they are being paid
on strike days they were paid all
through the pandemic they are
indemnified from any loss in this
dispute by a government that's prepared
to subsidize an attack on the rmt and on
my members to some ideological reason
and that is so that they drive down
working conditions and teach the rest of
the working class A lesson and we're not
going to accept that lesson from a
government of billionaires and oligarchs
so what we're going to do is stand by
the conditions and the agreements that
we've made the contracts that we've made
and we hope that other workers in
Britain will sympathize with that we get
vast amounts of support as I travel
about the network on non-strike days
people come up to me and shake my hands
they congratulate our members for this
steadfast resolve and they come up to us
on our picket lines which are all around
the country today and say keep going
until you get the result you need you
are fighting on and of course it's worth
noting as well that the strike action
the rmt had with network rail has been
paused you negotiate there what was on
the offer there with network Rel what
did you manage to get through with those
guys that you can't resolve with the
train operating companies
well they've added money to the deal the
two deals were were very similar up
until a few weeks ago and network rail
have added extra money our members will
get extra earnings in network Rail and
it's not available in this deal from the
train operating companies they've also
said that the the payoffer is not
conditional on us accepting the changes
that they want to bring in we'll deal
with those changes separately through
the machinery and through consultation
and through the safety regulator that
we've got but the network rail deal is
not conditional as on accepting these
changes that they're saying in the train
operating companies have to be adopted
so there is a way forward that all of
the industry knows what needs to be done
the chief Executives that we deal with
but it's the government the people in
Whitehall that are stopping a deal being
done I think they're going to wait for
everybody else to be settled until they
deal with the rmt that's the way they
conduct themselves it's come from Grant
straps and Rishi sunak and before then
Boris Johnson they see the rmt as some
kind of Target we're prepared to take
that on we think we've galvanized a lot
of change and a lot of change
fair enough the public will suffer while
you take that off people are suffering
what our people are suffering they lose
their wages the government is imposing
this dispute on the people and on the
passengers the government could settle
it tomorrow if they wish to they're
using the passengers that our members as
victims in the crossfire but their
ideological dispute with trade unions
and the anti-trade Union laws that they
want to bring in the suppression of
freedoms and all the rest of it all
right Mick Lynch General Secretary of
the rmt uh you're in talks of the
training praying company on Tuesday you
say and thank you for your time this
morning
okay cheers
all right let's take a look at what the
weather's got so it looked like it
started raining there in central London
now it's going to be modern unsettled
this weekend with some heavy downpours
to watch out for it's cloudy this
morning mostly but there is a scattering
of showers we just saw in central London
as well as some Mists and fog patches
more persistent rain is going to affect
The Western Isles
now let's uh take a look at some of the
stories making headlines this morning I
can bring in a fair Hagen and Pete price
to have a quick look through what we've
got I love how you do that you're always
changing your shirt lovely stuff right
let's uh crack through it and we've got
loads of time I want to get through
these if we can um Pete let's start with
you front page of the Daily Express uh
the headline there BBC faces Revolt if
license fee Rises what's that about
indeed the Silver Voice campaign uh has
decided that enough is enough if the
license goes up uh there's going to be a
revolution in this country and
apparently a lot of over 75s do not pay
uh their license fee
um the fees would cost me more than a
week's basic state pension to a lot of
people and really I do believe that
um they should give the license fee to
people over uh 75 because they've worked
all their life in this country and
they've had a bad time over money and
pensions by the way there's mine ready
to post uh after the show today it's on
pay me license fee so I'm one of the
honest ones you know it is crazy and it
is a Minefield and will they get rid of
the BBC's license fee and make them go
commercial we do not know but right now
it's too expensive give the over 75s I
think as the paper says on its front
page scrap for most over 75 so let's see
how that plays out I feel let's look at
the story you picked on the front of the
mirror and this is a a campaign that was
run but Mira said it's their campaign
but a lot of politicians got behind it
as well of course about trying to ban
the import of uh trophies well the heads
and body parts of animals that people
have killed
or at trophies they should call them
body parts that are a result of killing
wild animals in game Resorts uh usually
in southern Africa and I'm sure we can
all remember the case of Cecil the lion
who was shot by a U.S dentist in 2015
and that was kind of one of the
catalysts of this campaign so basically
uh there was a private member's bill
that has gone through Parliament is out
at the House of Lords and that prevents
the import of any of these trophies so
you have people who go to places in
South Africa they say that the the money
that they pay to hunt these animals goes
towards conservation which is a pretty
dubious claim and then they can bring
that the heads and the body parts you
know hang them up in their houses as you
know a sort of Pride piece but that has
now been banned and so there should be
no more of going uh to South Africa to
kill these beautiful animals and have
their heads hung up on your walls that
has been banned thank goodness yeah and
Pete you're shaking your head I want you
to comment on that but I'll take by the
shake of the head that you are fully
behind the decision to make that ban
legal all right let's uh let's go on
yeah I mean
mentality people it is hard to
understand sometimes all right let's
move to the inside page and this is one
we I think we can all agree on and this
is inside pages of the eye and uh you're
loving this one and I am too at the age
of 26
children finally agree that mummy Knows
Best
Mommy's always known best they are the
best people in the world it's Mother's
Day tomorrow to everyone that's still
got their mum look after your mum my mum
said to me get a proper job before you
go to show business I went into
hairdressing catering then found I could
do a job without smelling your chips and
here I am today but moms do know best
I'm glad your mum gave you that strong
advice to have a varied career p and
enough I mean it as Pete said it is
Mother's Day tomorrow so I shout outs
all the months I'll do that again
tomorrow on Mother's day but um it is
interesting to see that it takes until
people are 26 to finally realize I guess
that's just maturity right
yes I think it is certainly I mean my
daughter's 11 I'm not sure if she's ever
going to say that I know best but I
thought the best bit actually in this
article was where it said that people
are around or women around 30 when they
say they start turning into their mother
and I must admit that I I remember very
clearly the day that I realized I was
absolutely pounding into my mum even
though I said I never would but shout
out mom I know you're you're watching
good morning if I just ask you a fear
what's turning into your mum mean is
that a bad thing
it's not a bad thing but I remember like
I say all her phrases I do all the
things she used to do and I'm just like
my gosh I just have completely turned
into my mother and my brother and my dad
absolutely agreed imitation I'm doing
this for years imitation's the sincerest
form of Larry I fear so your mum will be
very very proud of you all right let's
move on quickly then to the to the next
story and it's a bit more serious now
but um let's take a look at this this is
when you picked out a fear this is Page
four of the Guardian about the dangers
of vaping and anyone that's been
anywhere and seen sort of teenagers
around they're all at it
yeah absolutely and some really shocking
statistics
um in this piece actually and at the
moment it says that vaping uh is having
some real growth
um around 11 to 15 year olds with 59 of
them using e-cigarettes up six percent
from 2018 and 18 of 15 year old vaping
and if it if the rapid growth and vaping
amongst the underway teens continues in
the way that it's going in five years
nearly all children under the age of 18
will be vaping which is absolutely
shocking for me research also shows that
and a lot of these kids did not smoke
beforehand so they're just taking up
vaping because it's seen as trendy but
let's remember that some of these do
have nicotine in them and they also have
chemicals and substances in them that we
don't know the effects on the lungs and
other parts of body because they just
haven't been around that for that long
and the research hasn't been done yeah
we have to leave it there for you thank
you but that is the point is that we
haven't had these things around for
longness we don't know what the damage
they may be causing